monsieur je vous souhaite la bienvenue
et vous remercie de votre disponibilité
pour répondre à nos questions nous avons
entamé les travaux de cette commission
d'enquête sur l'identification des
défaillances de fonctionnement au sein
des fédérations françaises de sport du
monde sportif et des organismes de
gouvernance du monde sportif le 20
juillet dernier l'Assemblée nationale a
décidé de sa création à la suite de très
nombreuses révélations publiques de
sportifs et sportifs et de diverses
affaires judiciaires et entré à la
gestion de certaines fédérations nos
travaux portent sur les violences
physiques sexuelle ou psychologique dans
le sport les discriminations sexuelles
et raciales et les problématiques liées
à la gouvernance financière des
organismes de gouvernance du monde
sportif vous avez notamment été chargé
par l'Église catholique de présider la
commission indépendante sur les abus
sexuels dans l'église cette commission
avait pour objectif de mieux saisir
l'ampleur des abus sexuels dans l'église
de proposer des pistes pour les traiter
et d'émettre des recommandations pour
prévenir leur réitération et réparer
leurs
conséquences votre nom est revenu à
plusieurs reprises au fil de nos
auditions le rapport rendu en octobre
2021 par la commission que vous présidez
comporte notamment des statistiques
intéressantes sur lesquelles nous
serions intéressés de vous entendre SAG
s'agissant des violences sexuelles sur
mineurs particulièrement n'avons-nous
pas le devoir de recenser le nombre de
victimes au sein du mouvement sportif
et de voir comment nous pouvons
contribuer à une réparation à indiquer
devant nous Brigit madame devant nous la
commission Madame Brigitte endriquez
pardon ancienne présidente du Comité
national olympique et
sportif en se référant aux travaux de la
sias monsieur Édouard Duran président de
la commission indépendante sur l'inceste
et les violences sexuelles faites aux
enfants donc la civise a comparer la la
relation qui peut s'instaurer entre un
sportif mineur et son entraîneur à celle
qui peut exister entre un prêtre et un
mineur y a-t-il des préconisations de
votre rapport dont notre commission
pourrait s'inspirer pour libérer la
parole et améliorer le cadre destiné à
prévenir détecter sanctionner les
violences dans le sport vous présidez
également le comité d'éthique des Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 et nous
pourrons également vous entendre sur
l'activité de ce comité je rappelle que
cette audition est ouverte à la presse
et qu'elle est retransmise en direct sur
le site de l'Assemblée nationale avant
de vous laisser la parole et entamer nos
échanges pendant environ 1 heure je vous
rappelle que l'article 6 de l'ordonnance
du 17 novembre 1958 relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires impose aux personnes
entendues par une commission d'enquête
de prêter serment de dire la vérité
toute la vérité rien que la vérité je
vous invite donc à lever la main droite
et à dire je le jure après avoir activé
votre micro S s'il vous plaît je le jure
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
et vous avez la
parole alors j'ai j'ai scrupule à à
m'exprimer sur le sujet de la
gouvernance des fédérations sportives je
n'ai absolument pas de légitimité et
d'expérience en la matière et j'ai eu
l'occasion de l'exposer aux
administrateur de votre commission
d'enquête par ailleurs ma ma récente et
temporaire mission de président des
comités d'éthique des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris dans la branche
comité d'organisation d'une part et Don
la branche société de livraison des
ouvrages
olympiques ne m'ont pas donner une
grande connaissance en réalité de la de
la gouvernance du mouvement sportif
maintenant sur l'organisation des Jeux
Olympiques évidemment je suis devenu
très très familier compétent et est
pointu en revanche sur l'organisation du
sport je suis toujours un peu novice
C remarque préalable étant fait je
voudrais en venir aux questions que vous
m'avez posé euh il y a un risque qui
doit être
prévenu dans le domaine du sport c'est
celui des violences de toute nature et
notamment celui des violences sexuelles
sexiste le premier risque que j'ai
identifié c'est le le risque d'atteinte
à la probité à
l'intégrité ce sont les problèmes de
conflit d'intérêt qui peuvent d'ailleurs
aussi déboucher sur des acte de
corruption alors je ne suis pas de ceux
qui considèrent l'école le sport ou les
famille comme pathogène par principe
mais il faut être lucide sur le fait
qu'aujourd'hui
encore
160000 mineurs sont chaque année
victimes de violence sexuelle dans tous
les milieux et que si l'on
regarde la population majeure en France
5400000 personnes ont selon l'enquête
menée par l'inerme avec l'appui de
l'ipope à la demande de la Commission
que j'ai présidé la siaz ont subi des
aggressions sexuelle pendant leur
minorité chaque enquête d'ailleurs
depuis 2008 confirmant et aggravant les
résultats de la précédente à mesure que
la parole des adultes se
libère voudrais dire donc que dans la
population majeure résidante en France
plus de 10 et demi% allèg avoir subi des
agressions sexuelles c'est-à-dire un peu
plus de 6 % des hommes et 14 % des
femmes la moitié de ces violences ont
été commises dans un cercle familial et
amical confè par exemple le film les
chatouilles d'Andrea bescon 216000 l'ont
été plus ou moins 40000 dans l'Église
catholique et
360000 soit 6 % du total si on ajoute
aux agressions commises par les prêtres
les religieux ou les religieuses les
agressions commises par des laïques en
mission d'église mais le sport comme
l'école comme les accueils collectifs de
mineurs colonie de vacan centre aéré et
cetera ne sont pas absents de ce bilan
qui figure expressément dans notre
rapport remis le 5 octobre
2021 il y a environ dans la population
majeure en France 180000 personnes qui
ont été victimes d'agression sexuelle
dans l'école publique plus de 100000
respectivement pour le sport et pour les
accueils collectifs de mineurs c'est pas
100000 pour deux c'est 100000 plus de
100000 pour le sport et plus de 100000
pour l'économie de vacances la tauinsu
certes on peut soutenir comme C a été
fait par certains cercle catholique
conservateur encore récemment d'ailleurs
en Espagne que les chiffres de la
commission que j'ai présidé ont été
délibérément et artificiellement gonflés
pour mettre à genou C l'Église
catholique et lui imposer l'agenda de
réforme de la commission que j'ai
présidé mais les expertises externes que
nous avons
commandité notamment auprès de l'INC et
de l'INED sur nos travaux en on confirmé
la validité et aucune autre étude n'est
venue en invalider les résultats
depuis maintenant plus de 2 ans je dois
dire que les quelques articles que j'ai
lu qui conteste nos analyses sont des
articles
pétris de complottisme de vérité
alternative et de dénis ce qui constitue
un désastre social majeur ne peut pas
rester sans réponse il me semble par
conséquent que dans toutes les instances
accueillant des mineurs il est ind
pensable de mettre en place des
dispositifs de recueil des signalements
d'écoute et d'enquête internes pour les
actes de
maltraitance il me semble que de tels
dispositifs ont déjà été mis en place
dans le domaine du sport si je lis
notamment quelques compte-rendus
d'audition que j'ai pu voir dans la
presse pour des raisons de simplicité
pour les appelants et plus largement de
crédibilité de ces dispositifs ceci
devrait s'il n'ont pas encore été créé
être mis en place à un niveau fédéral ou
même
interfédéral voire à celui du au niveau
du ministère des Sports si le sujet des
violences sexuelles est le plus sensible
et le plus urgent à prévenir et régler
l'écoute des personnes et le recueil des
signalements doivent s'étendre aux
situations de harcèlement aux violen
sexistes et à tous les acte attentatoire
à la dignité des personnes ces
dispositifs doivent non seulement
exister oui malheureusement j'ai une
bronchite et
c'est doivent non seulement exister mais
être visible aisément accessible apte à
écouter avec Tacte et professionnalisme
les appelants et capable de déclencher
des réponses rapides notamment des
enquêtes internes déépendante que la
justice pénale ait été saisie ou pas la
prévention et le signalement des mauvais
traitements
actuels ne devrait ne saurait cependant
à mes yeux suffire il me semble en effet
nécessaire au regard des conséquences de
long terme de ces actes en particulier
les violences sexuelles de mettre en
lumière ce qui s'est passé au cours des
décennies écoulées et d'instituer des
mécanismes de reconnaissance et de
réparation des violences subies lorsque
la justice ne peut plus être saisi pour
des raisons d'ancienneté des faits et de
prescription des infractions les
victimes des maltraitances et des
violences du passé devraient selon moi
être également écouté reconnu et
recevoir une forme de réparation adaptée
cette étape me semble indispensable à la
reconstruction de personnes qui ont été
profondément blessées par ce qu'elles
ont vécu or contrairement aux attentes
qui étaient les miennes lorsque j'ai
rendu publique le rapport sur les
violences sexuelles dans l'Église
catholique absolument rien de sérieux
n'a été engagé sur le thème des
violences sexuelles passées dans
l'ensemble des structures d'accueil des
mineurs qu'il s'agisse du sport mais
aussi de l'école de la protection de
l'enfance des mouvements de jeunesse de
l'éducation artistique des accueils
collectifs de mineurs et même des autres
cultes alors que alors que les
conséquences de ces violences pour les
mineurs qui les ont subis ont été et
reste dans plus de la moitié des cas
graves ou très graves d'après notamment
euh les enquêtes que nous avons mené mon
sentiment est que l'inaction dans ce
domaine s'est doublé d'une forme
d'hypocrisie car à chaque révélation de
violence passée on assiste au même jeux
de rô
interprété à la perfection on prend des
mines éplorées les pouvoirs publics
affichent leur indignation et leur
réprobation dans les termes les plus
sévères leur compassion aussi pour les
victimes avec le plein appui de
l'opinion il désigne à la vindicte
quelques bous émissaires le plus souvent
des entraîneurs sportifs plus rarement
tel président de fédération qui a été
particulièrement défaillant mais ce jeu
de rô entre guillemets évite de se
confronter au véritable problème et de
mettre à plat un passé bien plus sombre
que les quelques affaires révélées ici
ou là par les rares victimes en capacité
de parler publiquement de ce qui leur
est arrivé et de s'adresser à l'opinion
il permet aussi de se voiler la face sur
l'ampleur du mal et de ses conséquences
ainsi que sur les défaillances
systémiques qui ont pu se produire dans
les différents milieux enfin il n'pp
porte pas de réponse pertinente aux
problèmes et aux souffrances qu'un très
grand nombre de victimes de violence
sexuelle vivent sur une longue période
selon moi par conséquent seul une
commission d'établissement des faits
dans chaque grande institution publique
ou privée d'accueil des mineurs serait à
la hauteur des problèmes posés cette
étape est en effet indispensable à
l'engagement d'une démarche de
reconnaissance et de réparation des
conséquences des abus commis et donc je
forme le vœu que votre commission
d'enquête notamment puisse prendre
position sur ces sujets je vous
remercie on puisse reprendre le micro
ici merci
euh peut-être je vais commencer par une
question concernant euh la commission
indépendante par rapport à l'église donc
la siaz puisque c'est une commission
indépendante euh il y a eu des outils
qui ont été mis en place notamment je
pense à Signal sport par le ministère
des Sports pour le recueil des
signalements et des finalement de des
victimes dans le mouvement sportif et
euh au vu des différentes auditions
qu'on a pu avoir dans le cadre de cette
commission d'enquête on a parfois le
sentiment que le sport en tout cas les
fédérations ont du mal auront du mal à
se réformer d'elles-même pour avancer
sur ces questions est-ce que vous pensez
d'ailleurs ça a été quelquefois proposé
dans le cadre de cette commission
d'enquête qu'une commission indépendante
ou qu'une entité indépendante en charge
de ces questions de violence dans le
mouvement sportif euh est une solution
euh justement pour permettre de traiter
au bon niveau ou de la bonne manière
peut-être où voilà toutes ces affaires
de violence dans le mouvement sportif
oui je je pense enfin vous avez bien
compris que pour
moi il y a deux enjeux de niveau
différents c'est avoir donc un
dispositif
ou des dispositifs qui dans toutes les
structures d'accueil des mineurs soit
des dispositifs d'accueil et
d'écouteue de tout ce qui peut
dysfonctionner
euh on a vu notamment par exemple en
matière de harcèlement scolaire je
dirais le le besoin de d'une telle
écoute ça c'est la première branche
c'est véritablement le service minimum
qui s'impose avec une particulière
nécessité ou urgence si ça n'a pas été
fait et honnêtement je ne suis pas très
au clair sur euh
l'existence l'absence et l'efficacité de
ce type de dispositif dans le mouvement
sportif mais il y a une deuxième branche
c'est l'IMP l'impérieuse nécessité je
dirais de faire face au passé au passé
une profondeur du
champ vous savez quand j'ai présidé la
commission sur les abus sexuels dans
l'Église catholique c'était depuis le
début des années 50 j'ai reçu une lettre
d'une personne qui qui avait mon adresse
et qui me parle de ce qui lui est arrivé
dans un pensionnat des ieline dans les
années d'occupation entre 41 et 44 bon
voilà il y a un passé qui ne passe pas
et ce passé il faut savoir le regarder
et en tirer les conséquences d'où je
dirais ma ma 2e proposition c'est un
dispositif en réalité d'enquête sur le
passé à mon avis ces deux
dispositifs doivent être indépendants
naturellement ils doivent être financés
par selon le cas ça peut-être le
mouvement sportif ça peut-être des
cultes ça peut-être l'école l'école
publique mais être financé par ça ne
veut pas dire dépendre deeux au jour le
jour il faut naturellement que les deux
dispositifs je dirais d'écoute au fil de
l'eau de toutes les alertes sur des
violences qui peuvent être commises et
d'enquête et d'état des lieux sur le
passé soit vraiment indépendant comme
notre commission était indépendante moi
j'ai été nommé par la Conférence des
évêques et la conférence des religieux
et religieuses donc par des instances
catholiques
mais j'avais un budget c'est la seule
fois de ma vie où j'ai pu travailler euh
à à budget ouvert je n'avais pas de
plafond bien euh et j'ai pu m'organiser
comme je le souhaitais et donc il faut
naturellement que les les instance qui
existe soit euh je dirais totalement
maîtresse de leur ordre du jour de leur
méthodes de travail euh et qu'ell
puissent voilà euh avancer sans
interférence d'un quelconque pouvoir
hiérarchique fédéral interfédéral
ou ministériel ça c'est absolument
essentiel et naturellement en tant que
euh soit dans la mise à jour du passé
soit dans l'écoute
quotidienne de ce qui se
passe si là oou les
commissions sont conduites à faire des
constatations euh bah il faut d'abord
remédier à chacun individuel mais aussi
proposer enfin faire un diagnostic et le
cas échéant proposer des
solutions et et et proposer des des
solutions qui soit publiquement présenté
enfin je et à ce moment-là à ce
moment-là oui bien sûr s'il y a des des
commissions indépendantes qui
s'expriment qui font des
recommandations que avec des
recommandations publiques bah après je
veux dire le mouvement sportif en tirera
les conséquences comme d'ailleurs en ce
qui me concerne l'Église catholique tire
ou non les conséquences des
recommandations qu'on a faites et tout
ça se fait au vu et au-essus de tout le
public et et à ce moment-là je veux dire
les pouvoirs sportifs comme tous les
autres pouvoirs retrouvent ou pleinement
leur responsabilité parce que les
commissions indépendantes c'est bien
mais il y a aussi un moment où il faut
donner un espace propre à la gouvernance
des organes
concernés comment juridiquement agir à
l'encontre de ceux qui savent mais n'ont
rien dit ou protéger ceux qui parlent et
qui peuvent être sanctionnés
oui
je je je pense qu'il y a quand même le
le code pénal
euh le code pénal quand même permet
alors j'ai oublié
le le numéro des articles mais il permet
de sanctionner pénalement et de
poursuivre des personnes qui informaient
de mauvais traitement sur des mineurs ou
des personnes
vulnérables se sont
abstenus de tout acte utile par ailleurs
le même code
pénal a institué instittu un
délit pour les personnes qui connaissant
un crime ne l'ont pas dénoncé alors que
le crime pouvait être réitéré autrement
dit on a plutôt surabondance de base
juridiqueinsuffisance de base juridique
pour pour suivre
les les personnes qui ont été informées
qui ont su et qui n'ont rien
fait alors est-ce que sur ce sujet il
faut prévoir des règles particulières
notamment de
prescription nous avons considéré que
pour les crimes sexuels de
législateur je crois que c'est en
dernier lieu en
ou 2017 non c'est pas en 2017 c'est en
2018 ou 2019 à prorogé les délais de de
prescription notamment pour qu'en
matière
criminelle ce délai donc d'abord
commence à courir à l'âge de la majorité
et qu'il soit porté de 20 à 30 ans ce
qui fait qu'un mineur victime de
violence sexuelle pendant son enfance
peut jusqu'à l'âge de 48
ans dénoncer et provoquer les poursuites
fallait-il aller plus loin nous y avons
réfléchi dans le cadre de la commission
sur les abus sexuels dans l'église et
nous sommes arrivés à la conclusion en
dépit de la vie très majoritaire et même
quasiment unanime des associations de
victimes qu'il fallait
s'abstenir de de créer en fait une
imprescriptibilité pour ce type de crime
pensant et nous en avons fait je dire
l'expérience qu'il est extrêmement
difficile en la matière déjà de venir
plusieurs dizaines d'années après des
faits établir leur matérialité et
obtenir la condamnation par
conséquent la l'intime conviction de la
commission que j'ai j'ai présidé la
mienne également c'est que de tels
dispositifs
d'imprescriptibilité euh ne peuvent
qu'ajouter de la souffrance à la
souffrance euh notamment avec euh je
dirais le déroulement des enquêtes
pénales même si ce déroulement est
devenu euh infiniment plus adapté qu'il
n'était il y a 10 20 ou 30 ans mais euh
une enquête pénale et quelque chose
devant d'abord la police judiciaire puis
le juge d'instruction enfin la
juridiction de jugement c'est une
épreuve insoutenable pour beaucoup de
victimes et Infiné le risque est tout de
même élevé nous a-t-il semblé euh que on
ne puisse pas rapporter la preuve
d'agissement euh dont
euh je dirais la nature
même fait que il ne laisse pas de trace
à la différence je dirais des coups et
blessures des crimes de sang
euh et et par conséquent
euh voilà pas d'imprescriptibilité et
nous avons pris la même position pour
les délits qui sanctionnent l'absence de
dénonciation des auteurs d'infraction de
crime ou de mauvais traitement portés
sur des enfants et des personnes
vulnérables voilà euh alors qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire euh nous il nous est
apparu
euh bien plus adapté et ceci nous a été
reproché avec beaucoup de vigueur par
encore une fois un certain nombre de
milieux catholiquees et même des
conférences épiscopales étrangères il
est bien préférable de mettre en place
en réalité des dispositifs autonomes de
reconnaissance et de
réparation parce que on sort des débat
sur la prescription et on peut faire une
évaluation qui n'est pas une évaluation
judiciaire parce que l'évaluation
judiciaire son but c'est de caractériser
une infraction mais c'est de condamner
un auteur or les auteurs aussi dans
l'affaire dont je me suis occupé avaient
disparu ou étit hors d'âge dans une
majorité de cas et le sujet en réalité
ça n'est plus de condamner pénalement
des nonagénères à supposer qu'on le
puisse parce que prescription parce que
que problème de preuve le problème c'est
d'apporter une réponse pertinente aux
victimes et de faire en sorte qu'une
victime soit reconnu victime et j'ai
entendu et j'ai lu enfin des écrits de
personnes d'une mauvaise foi inoui dire
que la siaz avait recommandé de
condamner des personnes nous ne
condamnons personne nous ne nommons
personne nous ne nommons aucun coupable
nous reconnaissons en revanche
que des personnes ont été victimes oui
et bien ça ce travail làà on on peut le
faire et et sans se heurter à ce
parcours du combattant j'allais dire des
dispositions du Code pénal du code de
procédure pénale et le cas échéant des
règles de la prescription civile je
voudrais rappeler quand même que les
règles de la prescription civile ne
commencent à courir qu'à compté de la
consolidation des dommages et en la
matière euh l'expérience que j'ai
acquise c'est que le point de départ du
délai de prescription civile n'est pas
toujours aisé à fixer pas aisé et
souvent très
tardif alors euh maintenant sur les ça
j'ai parlé des victimes venons en aux
personnes qui n'ont rien fait alors
qu'elles savaient donc il y a la branche
poursuite pénale très bien euh et il
faut se garder de de la considéré comme
nul et non avenu et puis pour le
surplu nous avons tous une
responsabilité civique et sociale il est
pas interdit il est pas interdit puisque
là je m'adresse à une commission
d'enquête qui travaille sur le mouvement
sportif mais de mettre en place sur des
affaires déterminées des commissions
d'enquête internes pour voilà évaluer ce
qui s'est passé j'ai j'ai parlé de
dispositif indépendant d'écoute des
victimes mais ces dispositifs
indépendants peuvent sur des cas
particuliers déboucher sur des enquêtes
internes qui mettront à jour des
défaillances graves de personnes qui
savaient qui n'ont rien fait et et on
peut en tirer les conséquences de de
différentes manières vous
savez il y a pas de
prescription des fautes disciplinaires
c'est quelqu'un qui a commis une faute
disciplinaire
ben on va pas dire le délai de 5 ans
s'est écoulé et c'est terminé non on
doit pouvoir sanctionner des des Herms
voilà et tout le monde doit répondre de
ses actes tout le monde doit répondre de
ses
actes alors peut-être juste pour
préciser
là-dessus sur des personnes qui ont
alors nous peut-être pour reprendre un
peu la manière dont sont aussi déroulés
les travaux c'est que la plupart des
victimes qu'on a pu entendre ici sont
des personnes qui ont été qui ont subi
des violence sexuelle qui étaient très
jeune et qui ont témoigné très longtemps
après donc elles ont mis énormément de
temps à
pouvoir témoigner de ce qu'elles ont
vécu pour certaines d'entre elles
d'ailleurs elles avaient témoigné en
tout cas elles en avaient parlé au
moment où les faits se sont produits
elles n'ont jamais été entendu il ne
s'est jamais rien passé donc la première
question c'est pour les personnes qui
étaient au courant même si derrière il y
a un classement sans suite pour
prescription ou autre ça veut dire qu'il
n'y a pas de délai de prescription sur
la faute qui a étéit de ne pas dénoncer
donc juste pour préciser est-ce que
c'est bien le cas ou pas et il y a une
autre proposition qui a été faite dans
le casadre de cette commission c'est la
reconnaissance de l'amnésie
traumatique est-ce que pareil sur la sur
à ce sujet là vous auriez bah du coup un
avis sur reconnaissance ou pas parce
qu'on a aussi évoqué l'imprescribilité
des viols sur mineurs donc j'entends que
la décision n'a pas été dans ce sens
mais voilà ce sont des questions aussi
qui se sont posées à nous dans le cadre
de cette
commission la
première parade que vous avez envisagé
avant l'amnésie traumatique
c'était
alors la première question c'était euh
depuis plusieurs semaines maintenant on
en a reçu ici des présidents de
fédération des personnes du monde
sportif qui nous indiquent euh ça se
savait tout le monde était au courant il
y avait des bruits et cetera sauf qu'ils
n'ont pas déclenché d'enquête ni interne
ni autre pas de signalement au titre de
l'article
40 et parfois certaines affaires quand
elles ont été traitées par la justice
parce que la victime a fini par aller
porter plaines elles sont classées sans
suite ma question c'est est-ce que ces
personnes même si l'affaire a été
classée sans suite est-ce qu'on peut
toujours les pours suivre pour non
assistance à personne en danger pour le
fait de ne pas avoir signalé ou de ne
pas avoir diligenté des enquêtes
internes alors qu'elles en avaient la
responsabilité alors
euh enfin ce que ce que vous
rapportez fait tellement
penser à ce qui s'est passé dans
d'autres contexte institutionnel au sens
cela se savait il y avait des bruit les
enfants parlent entre eux d'ailleurs
mais en réalité personne ne faisait rien
euh et donc vous le dites pas d'enquête
interne et aujourd'hui quand on va au
pénal classement sensuite parce que
parce
que les éléments constitutifs de
l'infraction sont extraordinairement
difficiles à rapporter alors quand on
est dans ce contexte
c'est une impasse je ne vois pas comment
après le classement sans suite de fait
pouvant être constitutive d'infraction
on puisse poursuivre sur le plan pénal
des personne au motif qu'elle savait je
veux
dire à la fin savait quoi Savit qu'il y
avait des infractions s'il y a des
infractions les infractions sont
constatées si les infractions ne sont
pas constatées je veux dire on on va pas
pouvoir poursuivre pénalement enfin sous
réserve de cas d'espèce que j'arrive
même pas à concevoir et on va pas
pouvoir euh condamner pénalement en tout
cas poursuivre avec une chance sérieuse
de renvoie devant une juridiction de
jugement et une condamnation on on ne
peut pas arriver à une condamnation de
de personnes qui a entendu parler de
bruit en revanche moi je pense que
euh il y a des conséquences à tirer en
dehors du champ
pénal sur les responsabilités qu'on
confie à une personne alors vous
comprenez si c'était il y a 30 ans
honnêtement je pense que tous les
acteurs sont rangés des voitures donc
c'est terminé mais si ce sont des faits
tout de
même récent pas trop ancien même s'ils
n'ont pas été constatés pénalement mais
qu'on est dans un
contexte de de de rumeurs de de
dénonciations qui ont été faites qui
n'ont pas eu de suite à mon avis on peut
en tirer des conséquences sur
aujourd'hui les responsabilités qui
peuvent être conférées aux personnes
concernées on n pas obligé de les faire
passer par la case du box du tribunal
correctionnel vous voyez bien pour des
faits qui se sont produits il y a 15 ou
20 ans hein c'est donc assez longtemps
mais avec des personnes qui aujourd'hui
sont toujours en responsabilité en
responsabilité en l'absence même en
l'absence même de condamnation pénale de
ces personnes en
responsabilité on peut tout de même
regarder les faits les signaux qui ont
été adressés et une espèce de forme de
carence de carence généralisée il me
semble que dans beaucoup d'institutions
publ ou privé on ne fait pas ou on ne
ferait pas autrement on ne ferait pas
autrement
euh et et il faut tout de même en tirer
les conséquences surtout si les
personnes concerné euh ont toujours un
rôle actif à jouer euh dans dans le
champ sportif qui est l'objet de vos
préoccupations alors l'amnésie
traumatique
euh je n'ai aucun doute aucun doute
alors que je n'ai aucune compétence ni
en matière médicale ni en matière de
psychiatrie de de psychanalyse mais elle
existe c'est une évidence
euh et donc et spécialement dans dans
dans cette matière
une des raisons pour lesquelles le
législateur a reporté de 20 à 30 ans la
prescription si je me souviens bien des
débats de cette époque c'est parce qu'un
certain nombre de personnes en
particulier des femm
euh revivent
ou se réapproprient leur passé au moment
où leurs propres enfants ont
l'âge qu'ells av avit lorsqu'elles ont
été agressées autrement dit euh une
femme on va dire de 40 ans ou 45 ans qui
a une fille de 10 à 13 ans au moment où
sa fille a 10 13 14 ans elle peut je
dirais en tant que mère euh retrouver ce
qu'elle a vécu à l'âge auquel elle a été
victime parce qu'elle a un fils ou une
fille de cet âge-là ça je je crois tout
à fait à à la pertinence de de cela
est-ce
que ça doit conduire un allongement du
délai de prescription au-delà de ce
qu'il est 30 ans parce qu'au-delà de 30
ans il faut être clair c'est
l'imprescriptibilité
euh je je ne le pense pas enfin notre
rapport je je vous y renvoie on a pesé
vraiment tout à fait les les les
arguments vraiment en conscience je
crois que ce serait un mauvais choix et
et je l'ai complètement assumé devant
les associations de victimes et et ce
qu'on a appelé le groupe victime de la
sias qui était un peu notre
interlocuteur et vis-à-vis duquel il y a
eu tout un débat en amont et vis-à-vis
duquel moi j'ai présenté le rapport en
aval avant même qu'il ne soit rendu
publique
alors moi je voudrais peut-être revenir
parce que vous avez évooqué à plusieurs
reprises la notion de
réparation c'est aussi quelque chose
qu'on a entendu de la part des victimes
dans le cadre de ces
auditions je vous avoue qu'on on est en
réflexion aussi là-dessus sur ce que
pourrait être la réparation nous on a vu
bon des victimes qui ont beaucoup de mal
et d'ailleurs pour certains d'entre
elles qui ne se sont toujours pas
reconstruite qui ont trouvé peu de
d'accompagnement et de soutien de la
part de leur mouvements sportifs ou de
leur fédération ou de leur club et qui
ont eu de grandes difficultés à avoir
une aide de l'ordre psychologique
parfois aussi pour pouvoir se
reconstruire et et finalement aller de
l'avant donc peut-être revenir sur cette
notion de réparation et comment qu'elle
prendrait forme finalement pour ses
victimes là je je pense parce que en la
matière et sans vouloir à nouveau
ramener sur la table les proposition de
la Commission que j'ai présidé il faut
faire du neuf il faut créer quelque
chose
exnilo hein il y a rien sur les étagères
moi je pense que la première chose dont
les victimes ont besoin c'est d'être
reconnu comme victime hein et il m'est
arrivé dans les nombreuses
auditions que que j'ai faite et et
dont je ne me suis pas complètement
remis il m'est arrivé de poser on
faisait toujours les auditions binô un
homme une
femme et de poser à la fin bon la
question voilà qu'est-ce que vous
attendez aujourd'hui et notamment
qu'est-ce que vous attendz aussi de la
commission qui qui vous a entendu et il
y a eu des
réponses très touchante très
bouleversante ce que j'attendais et je
croyais que c'était
inaccessible c'était de pouvoir parler
d'être entendu et d'être visiblement cru
et ça vous me l'avez donné vous nous
l'avez donné bon c'est des auditions ça
dure 2h 2h3 il faut prendre le temps il
faut je un minimum d'empathie quand même
c'est
pas même quand on a fait l'École
nationale d'administration on peut être
capable de de de de ce mouvement
d'empathie enfin je ça c'est la
reconnaissance mais cette reconnaissance
au-delà des auditions que nous avons
fait
elle est
aujourd'hui en cours de déploiement par
les deux commissions indépendantes qui
ont été mises en place par l'Église
catholique linir l'Institution nationale
indépendante de reconnaissance et de
répar
pour les violences sexuelles commises
par des prêtres diocésains et la
commission la CRR la commission de
reconnaissance et de réparation qui a
été mise en place elle par la Conférence
des religieux et religieuses de France
pour les victimes des membres des
congrégations hein et et donc il y a ce
ce travail de de reconnaissance qui qui
se fait là depuis les instance sont été
mis en place dans le principe en
novembre 2021 elles ont commencé à
travailler effectivement au printemps de
2022 ça fait 18 mois que les instances
fonctionnent et il y a à l'heure
actuelle un peu plus de 2000 demandes de
reconnaissance et de réparation qui ont
été faites alors
au-delà de la reconnaissance la question
de la réparation et dans une approche de
justice restaurative et en ligne avec
les recommandations de la
commission nous avons considéré que la
réparation euh ne devait pas exclure
l'argent mais ne pouvait pas non plus
uniquement se réduire ou se limiter au
versement d'une somme d'argent et donc
il faut à
partir je dirais d'un
récit d'une prise de conscience des
conséquences des des violences sexuelles
euh aussi d'un barê parce qu'à la fin il
faut tout de même un
barê à il y a une grille d'évaluation
qui est une grille d'ailleurs
transversal pour l'ensemble des des
victimes de l'Église catholique qui a
été mise en place et qui permet
euh de tenir compte des conséquences
dommageables des actes qui ont été
commis alors c'est c'est une grille qui
d'ailleurs quand on voit ce que sont euh
les réparations versé par le fond de
garantie des victimes d'infraction dont
l'auteur est insolvable ou
inconnu les
réparations le le barême des des des
réparations des des instances mises en
place par l'Église catholique est plus
favorable que ce que fait le fond de
garantie des victime hein alors le fond
de garantie des victimes lui il a pas de
barême mais on voit bien ce que sont les
indemnisations moyennes pour une
agression sexuelle de nature délictuelle
et d'autre part une agression criminelle
et et donc là il y a un moment où il
faut et par exemple vous comprenezi
enfin moi ce que j'ai vraiment
découvert c'est je dirais la
disproportion et l'absence de connexion
entre les actes commis et les
conséquences quand on a été formé à la
rue discipline du code pénal on se dit
bah voilà il y a les infractions
contravention de 5e classe le délit le
délit puni de 3 ans 5 ans 10 ans et puis
après le crime
et bon c'est vrai que les conséquences
d'un crime sont en général bien plus
graves que les conséquences d'un délit
mais tout n'est pas automatique il faut
aussi prendre en compte notamment la
question des soins et euh soit dit en
passant
euh il y a
euh un document qui a été émis euh par
le pape
François au début du mois de
mai 2020 je
crois et qui dans les obligations de
réparation insiste sur le soin quand on
sait ce que coûte la prise en charge
psychiatrique
psychothérapeutique des victimes d'abus
sexuel là je veux dire face à mes
détracteurs disant cette commission est
complètement irresponsable elle ne vise
qu'un seul but aussi c'est de ruiner
l'Église catholique réponse mais
prenez-vous-en au pape nous sommes en
dessa de ces recommandations nous sommes
en DEA de ces recommandationsin j'ai
j'ai oublié le le titre qui est un titre
latin bien sûr de
la du du document en question mais c'est
c'est saisissant enfin quand on voit ça
on se dit qu'on est on est très très
très en de ça d'une réparation en fait
intégrale oui l'idée n'est-ce pas qui
qui est importante dans notre rapport
c'est qu'on dit que cette réparation ne
doit pas être forfaitaire au sens il y a
un barê et vous avez un chèque et c'est
terminé et notamment moi certaines
personnes m'ont dit si l'Église
catholique croit pouvoir s'en sortir en
reconnaissant les faits en nous faisant
un chèque comme ça on aura vraiment
impression que c'est le prix d'une passe
hein non mais ça c'est il y a une et
donc je dirais l'argent enfin de toute
façon ce préjudice ce type de préjudice
est irréparable ça c'est le premier
point ensuite il peut y avoir des
compensations qui doivent tenir compte
autant qu'il est possible autant qu'il
est possible des dommages et des
conséquences des des des agression
sexuelle
et tout ça dans le cadre effectivement
de d'un barê qui je crois monte à 70000
80000 €
et je pense honnêtement
que rien de ce qui a été décidé en aval
du rapport que nous avons fait et rien
d'ailleurs de nos recommandations ne
s'impose à qui que ce soit mais que ça
peut-être une base de réflexion et euh
je dirais de discussion pour euh des des
structures publiques ou privées qui
veulent s'attaquer à ce sujet mais ma
mon intime conviction c'est qu'on ne
peut pas ne rien
faire euh est-ce que c'est cette grille
dont vous nous parlez dont vous nous
avez parlé est-ce qu'elle est publique
est-ce qu'on peut y avoir
accès ah oui je je pense que elle existe
et
notamment notamment son son plafond il y
a eu quelques controverses au mois de
janvier de cette année à la suite d'une
émission de
télévision
[Musique]
sur je dirais le thème l'Église
catholique ne veut pas payer
et cetera et cetera et à ce moment-là on
a parlé du
plafond il faut demander à la présidente
de l'inir ou au président de la CRR la
communication de ce document mais je je
ne pense pas que ce document est un
quelconque caractère
secret quant à mon titre je ne suis plus
président de la commission indépendante
sur les av sexuel dans l'église je suis
ancien Président la Commission a remis
son rapport le 3 le 5 octobre 2021 comme
vous l'avez rappelé et désormais elle
n'a plus aucune activité et notamment
elle n'est pas chargée du suivi de ses
recommandations et elle a pris bien soin
dans le rapport que nous avons remis le
5 octobre 2021 de dire que notre mission
s'arrêta on s'occupe
uniquement de la
question je dirais de nos archives nous
avons toujours un suivi parce qu'il y a
des des demandes d'accès à nos archives
qui ont été versées aux Archives
nationales ça c'est c'est la première
chose et et la deuxième chose il y a une
sorte de je dirais de droit moral sur ce
que nous avons fait et de temps en temps
nous prenons collectivement position
pour justifier des des affirmations que
nous avons
faites nous avons auditionné monsieur
Édouard Durand comme je vous le disais
dans les propos liminires le président
de la civise qui souhaite voir péréniser
sa sa commission indépendante qu'en
pensez-vous la proposition d'eddouard
Duran est
contreintuitive mais je pense que
qu'elle répond
à un besoin la civise a identifié a
entendu près de 30000 victimes
d'agression sexuelle dans tous les
cadres essentiellement la famille la
famille et les amis de la famille c'est
50 % des des agressions et je pense
que ce travail à mon avis doit être
poursuivi il est important que les
victimes soient accompagnées car nous
avons un appareil médical qui est
formidable de prévention
mais cette question des violences
sexuelles sur mineur est tellement grave
elle a été tellement occulté puis
sous-estimé qu'il n'y a pas commune
mesure
entre le coût du maintien de la
prolongation de cette
commission et je dire les
bénéfices c'est pas des bénéfices
politiqu ce sont mais mais des bénéfices
réels invisibles je pense aussi même sur
nos comptes publics et nos comptes
sociaux
car cette
affaire ça n'est pas
uniquement la constellation ou la jute
apposition de malheur individuel c'est
aussi c'est un désastre collectif qui a
une grande qui a un grand impact qui a
un grand impact sur notre système de
santé notre système de soins et venir
dire que bah il y a un ministère de la
Santé qui a des ARS qui a l'assurance
maladie et cetera je veux bien oui bien
sûr mais je pense que de temps en temps
pour des affections ou
des comment des des des séismes de de la
nature ou de l'ampleur des des abus
sexuels il y a besoin pendant une
certaine durée que je qualifierai pas
est-ce que c'est ans est-ce que c'est
plus il y a besoin de de de maintenir
cette structure et je suis donc en total
accord avec Édouard Durand
oui vous souhaitiez intervenir à nouveau
non donc nous vous remercions votre
participation à cette commission
d'enquête vous n'hésitez pas bien
évidemment à revenir vers nous si vous
avez des compléments d'information ou
des propositions également concrète à à
nous transmettre à cette commission
d'enquête je vous transmettrai mon
exposé liminaire merci
beaucoup